foreign
he has gotten to where he will get in
the shower just essentially rinse off so
he won't shampoo
he won't lock his body listen you have
to understand this from 11 to about 22
boys become allergic to soap
[Music]
what's up this is John with the Dr John
deloney's show
greatest mental health in marriage and
relationship podcast ever
ever
greatest parenting show of all time
saying it enough it becomes the truth or
so they say hey if you want to be on
this show we talk about everything from
addiction to abuse to Healing from
traumas to uh I think my marriage is
over to I think I want to get married
uh we talk about everything and my
here's my promise I'm gonna do the best
I can to mix
the most cutting-edge science which with
my experience working with people over
two decades with my academic experience
and with my own personal Journey walking
through this mess myself trying to
figure out how to be a dad I promise I'm
gonna sit down with you I'm not going to
judge you I'm not gonna be mad with you
and we're gonna figure out the next
right thing to do
and if you want to be on the show give
me a call at
1-844-693-3291 that's
1-844-693-3291 or go to John deloney.com
ask a s k and we will get you on the
show and we'll go from there let's go to
Kyle in Valparaiso what's up Kyle
hey what's up Dr John how are you doing
I'm good my brother what about you man
hey I'm hanging in there uh life's
pretty crazy but but uh
um thanks for calling man it means a lot
to me what's up
um yeah so almost a year ago
um I left my stable yet very
unfulfilling job
um just went all in on starting my own
business which was something that I
always wanted to do
um
also uh my wife and I we purchased our
first house in March and then we got
married in September so because why not
you know throw all this stuff in why not
um and we bought a pony anyways yeah so
it's my first business I've had
um and so it's it's stressful and um
I've noticed a lot of like some
unhealthy thought patterns that I've had
my whole life
um but they've really like come on
strong with this you know this big life
change
um and uh my wife is is very supportive
of me
um I feel very lucky to have her uh
sometimes though I feel like with these
you know these thought patterns
intrusive thoughts I can push her away
um so to get more into detail on that
um I've always had like a very active
mind I've struggled a lot with intrusive
thoughts um obsessive thinking
perfectionism
um and it's hard for me to control
sometimes and so like something little
could come up in the day
um let's say with my business like oh um
I'm not where I think I should be or I'm
not um didn't make the right choice or
I'm not making enough money I don't have
enough customers and then you know
something little could just snowball
very quickly go from zero to 100 very
quickly and I can't stop it and then all
of a sudden you know the world's ending
and I want to stop you know quit the
business because I'm failing
um and so these outside things have like
very strong hold on on how I how I feel
let me interrupt you there what's that
let me interrupt you there
you have given external
people and systems and opinions that
sort of grasp
right and this this will be the
Cornerstone of you either getting well
or you not
because if you believe that you are
subject to that you are a slave to these
outside things this the reports the what
then you will always be spinning your
wheels duct taping over the the the the
leaks in the dam right you will always
be trying to to patch over well I'm
anxious over here and I'm not sleeping
over here so I'm just gonna ignore this
I'm gonna quit doing this I'm gonna stop
talking to this person I'll quit this
job and get this job I'll quit that job
and get this job you're going to be
moving around until you take ownership
over
huh
my body's been trying to keep me safe
for a long long time
and it does that by trying to dress
rehearse Tragedy by hot trying to think
of the worst thing that could possibly
happen ever and reverse engineer what we
need to do right now to prevent fill in
the blank uh there's a great quote by
um Victor Frankl I think it is that and
I'll I'll butcher the quote but
anxiety will fill as much space as you
give it
and so what I would ask you is
what's the earliest you can remember
these intrusive thoughts where you would
just Spin and spin and spin and spin and
spend
um
I mean since apple is probably like you
know seven or eight
um
you know I don't have like the specific
examples but I would just always be in
my head and and struggle to
to like pay attention school for example
um uh I don't I don't know like exactly
what I was thinking about but I could
just always remember
just always being in my head
was speaking your opinions out loud
something that was frowned upon
um no not not in my not hot in like my
house or anything but it it was it was
always difficult for me like I struggled
with you know self-esteem as a kid
um what's the origin of that though so
I'm trying to get at
yeah
um
somebody told you either affirmatively
like oh you're too small to play ball or
you're not fast enough or your military
material they told you crap like that or
they didn't look at you and say
God Almighty every day I'm so grateful
that I get to be your mom I get to be
your dad I get to be your teacher
yeah
um
I mean my parents are awesome they they
um
they uh best parents I you know I could
ask for
um so I think I I just feel like you
know the
I mean I thought I was born with the the
attention issues and the the
um
you know the struggling to focus and
intrusive thoughts I mean maybe that's
not how that works but that's what it
feels like the way the the best way I've
heard explained is from the great brene
Brown she says in genetics loads the gun
but environment pulls the trigger
right and what's beautiful about that is
is that you and I can both be wired up
for certain things
but if it's the environment that sets
these things off that means there's
something in it that we can control
and so instead of trying to solve for
the each individual anxiety I mean
anxious in front of people I'm anxious
for this thing I mean I want to create a
non-anxious life
yeah and I want to work from there
and so you need to hear me say out loud
rumination
worrying
literally solves nothing
nothing absolutely nothing
and it it was like a light bulb moment
when I first someone first told me that
I think it was a counselor friend of
mine first told me that
because I my my life was like a better
mind remember that movie I was always
waiting for this so that this could
happen and then I could sell this and
then this was going to happen and I was
talking to my wife this morning in fact
I'm writing another book on anxiety and
this morning my wife and I were talking
about it and I asked her what was it
like and she said you always had a new
thing that was going to be the final
solution
and she said I would listen to you and
you were nuts you were going to get this
other job or you just needed to do this
one thing so that this one person would
see you so you could get this promotion
and then make this much money and then
it would be okay or right I'm just gonna
I'm gonna go be a full vegan I'm gonna
be a raw vegan and that's gonna fix the
I just always had a thing and I was so
confident in the thing she said that she
felt crazy and she knew she wasn't crazy
but her body told her she was anyway you
see what I'm saying like it's always
this thing until I realized none of
those things are going to solve
a life that has nothing to Anchor into
right so let's back all the way out
give me the names just the first names
of two or three or four men in your life
that you love and you hang out with
regularly and you don't have to hide
anything from
um
first names you said yep
okay
um
Scott
[Music]
um
I think that's about it that's it and
you see those guys those two guys
regularly once a week once every time
regularly
not regularly I uh what did they say
when you told them hey I'm really
struggling with anxiety
hey uh
I've been told I think I think I told
Kyle about it here's what I'm getting at
here's what I'm getting at
you have to have people in your life
that you can be honest and tell the
truth to and you don't have that
right you have people in your life that
you protect and you take care of and you
hang out with
but not people that I would consider in
your tribe
right and my guess is if your marriage
is like mine
you've begun to keep secrets from your
wife about how scared you are that you
quit your your steady job
that you thought starting your own
business you'd be a little more
successful than you are right now and
you thought it would make you feel
differently and it hasn't
and
so you sit on that because you don't
want to freak her out or make her any
more nervous than she already is and all
that and that creates space and that
space is called dishonesty you're not
telling her the truth
and she feels it doesn't know what to do
with it and so she tries to solve it
and she creates a whole a world that she
can survive in
because she doesn't know what's
happening in your world it just feels
Electric in there
and your body feels that she is heading
off into another Direction so it spins
faster you see what I'm saying this
whole thing creates a dance yeah
yeah and so for the first time in your
life probably
you've got to find a couple of people
including her and say the words I'm
scared
I am spinning out my thoughts are
spinning out I'm exhausted and the only
way I only path forward I can see is to
work faster and harder
and I don't know if I got that
you have to speak these fears out loud
because here's what your body will do it
will link the terror part of it's your
brain
with your frontal lobe with the thinking
part and it will go oh he recognizes the
threats we don't have to keep banging on
these drums in the back of his head
he's driving he's aware
and then you can actually start solving
some of these things because the alarms
will begin to go down that's number one
that's connectivity number two are you
safe do you owe money to people
no no you don't owe anybody any money
no okay are you do you have abusive
employees are you in a unsafe business
have you bitten off more than you could
chew with your business
no no not at all okay are y'all making
money you're gonna make your make your
house notes and things
yeah yeah Okay cool so the more repair
mortgage and stuff oh great so you just
said you didn't owe anybody any money
beside your mortgage who do you owe
money to
uh student loans car notes credit cards
student loans
um
[Music]
okay when I say do you owe anybody any
money and you say no those are people
you owe money to okay okay I am
convinced I I I heard it wrong I am
convinced with all of my guts
that the our frontal lobes our thinking
brain
will can understand oh this is a great
purchase this is zero percent down this
is a good interest rate or whatever
but the amygdala the part of I probably
even go as far as say the HPA access the
entire system knows
if one thing happens in this business we
don't make the car note they come take
the car it ruins my credit I can never
borrow again I don't have a bit rate see
where it starts spinning out on us I'm
convinced with all of my guts
that if you owe money to somebody your
body will not let you rest because it
knows at its core level
that you're not safe
because at any moment this stuff goes
away
and so whatever you got to do I want you
to stay on the line I'm going to send
you some stuff I'm going to send you the
Financial Peace University the class
that gets to help you get out of debt
and I know you didn't call for this but
I'm convinced that it's a it's a
marriage tool also and it's an
anti-anxiety tool also because it's
going to force you and your wife to sit
down and talk through what are our goals
and who do we want to become as a couple
and it's going to force you into a plan
if you if you choose to you can throw in
the garbage for all I care but it's
going to cheat it's going to force you
into a plan that's going to help you not
owe anybody anything and it's going to
let your brain finally go
and I'm telling you this as a guy that
had a six-figure mortgage and six-figure
student loan debts because I got a bunch
of stupid degrees actually they're not
stupid I'm proud of them I had a bunch
of degrees and I had a bunch of credit
card debt I had a car note
and the difference between that guy
and me now is a radically different
person
the stressors in my life are tenfold
what they were
but my body isn't constantly if we I get
fired tomorrow that'll suck but I'm not
gonna miss a meal No One's Gonna Come
Take My House away from me
you see what I'm saying that is a that
is a different Legacy that's number two
so we're talking about connection we're
talking about safety and the third one
is autonomy
who decides what you do tomorrow is it
you or is it this business that you have
a business loan on is it Toyota Motor
Company
who decides what you do tomorrow
who decided and I decide
you sure
can you take can you take tomorrow off
and just go spend the day with your wife
uh probably not no you can't that means
somebody else is pulling your strings
and so what I want you to do is to go
down a list of who has their hooks in
you
who decides what you do tomorrow
now and I obviously tomorrow is is maybe
it's a bad example maybe you got a big
business meeting and things like that
that's I totally get that
but I'm talking on a global level
if your brain knows
that you are not driving the car
somebody else says you've outsourced
that to a mortgage company to a boss to
a business that you're underwater in
whatever it's not going to let you rest
it doesn't it can't afford for you to go
all the way under into deep REM sleep
because you're not safe
they can't afford for you to spend time
having sex
this isn't a time to reproduce this is a
time to not die right that's the it's an
ancient system that we got designed to
keep us from getting eaten by bears but
it's running all the time all right so
backing all the way all the way out
here's what I've had to do I keep and if
you're watching this on YouTube I've got
this I've
got a notebook that I got you may have
heard me talk about this on the show and
I still carried around with me
everywhere everywhere and I've got not
hundreds I've got dozens of these
journals over the last decade that I've
got in a drawer in my house in a filing
cabinet that I'm still deciding whether
to give to my kids or not one day or
just putting them in the fire pit
outside
but it's a thoughts Journal
and here's what I do I I keep my
gratitude journal in here now
every day I wake up and say hey here's
five things I'm grateful for and that's
just that's just a spiritual practice
that I recommend you do the second thing
is every time your brain starts to spin
out on you
stop literally say out loud nope nope
stop nope
and write down is this true whatever the
story is so here's a good example
um my daughter I think I've told this
this on the show before
um I kissed my six-year-old daughter on
the forehead as I was walking out of the
of the house to go to the gym at like
five in the morning or something
and she turns around and yells I wish
you never existed all you ever tell me
is that I'm smart and Brilliant and
beautiful and I can't live like this I'm
not going to take it anymore
and I was like whoa and so I walked
outside on the front porch and the first
thought that came in my mind the very
first thought is
of course because you suck at being a
dad
you're never here you're always on the
road you're always prepping for some
talk or writing some stupid book of
course she doesn't want you kissing on
their head because you suck at this
and that haunted me for about 45 seconds
and then I made it down to the my
basement gym and I pulled this little
notebook out and I wrote down in it you
suck at being a dad period and then I
looked at it and I asked myself the
magic question is this true
the answer is no it's not I'm a great
dad I'm a good dad maybe I'm not great
I'm good at it and I work really hard at
it
and in that process I stopped the cycle
before it started the one that begins to
solve for you're a bad dad and fills my
body with cortisol and adrenaline and
now I'm off to the race isn't what I
need to do I need to lose weight but I
can't lose weight because I've been
doing this and I got to quit my job but
I can't do my job you know what I'm
talking about because you get on that
road all the time right
so I'm gonna stop that sucker on the
front end because I know that ruminating
and worrying is not helping my problems
and now that I know that I'm going to
consciously practice stopping that train
before it leaves the station right as
it's leaving the station and it
occasionally one gets out and when it
goes I'm gonna smile at it I'm gonna be
curious about and be like oh there it
goes
oh boy here we go it's like getting
stuck on a roller coaster and like and
so it's gonna go and I go here we go I'm
gonna be curious about it I'm not going
to allow myself to get anxious about
being anxious again
right
and that's where you are you're worried
about being worried about things at this
point right
yes exactly yes let me ask you this last
question
is your business going to make it
um I hope so I'm not sure nope own
reality is it gonna make it or not make
it
it's gonna make it what's the business
it is uh residential cleaning business
okay
and so it's like uh you hire people to
go clean clean homes
yeah okay are you making a profit
a little bit not much okay what's the
scalability
scalability
um I think it's it's it's very scalable
um
I'm just working on getting more clients
and then so I could hire more teams and
uh I think it's
I mean there's a lot of a lot of people
living here so I think there's a lot
a lot of um opportunity
so here's what I want you to do I want
you to find two or three people
either in the Valparaiso or get in a car
and drive a few hours to
a couple of cities that are around you
that are big go over to Indianapolis
go over to Chicago find somebody who
runs a cleaning business
I want you to offer to buy them
dinner
and just say I need some mentoring and
coaching
I need you to walk me through what does
this look like
like what does success look like
how have you found success in getting
new clients or is it it's it's word of
mouth is it this is it that
um here in the office a whole bunch of
people use the same crew some use it a
couple times a week because they're rich
other people use it once a month use
them once a month but it all is word of
mouth right so I sit with somebody who's
doing the thing you want to do at the
level you want to do it
and ask them humbly take a knee and say
hey I'm into this thing up to my
eyeballs I'm starting to spin out a
little bit
where the pitfalls where I need to go
from here
and you're going to get some real wisdom
not from YouTube not from you doing back
of the napkin math or coming up with yet
another spreadsheet and another
spreadsheet you're gonna get some real
wisdom from some people who have already
been there okay so hang on the line I'm
gonna send you Financial Peace
University I'm going to see the every
dollar app for free too for a year I'm
also going to send you a copy of own
your pass change your future two I'm
just need two copies I want you to read
one I want your wife to read the other
one okay I want y'all to do this
together okay and I'm gonna send you a
copy of my book redefining anxiety I'm
just gonna load you up brother because I
am you I've been there
and I need you to hear me say before I
get off the phone there is a light at
the end of this tunnel if and only if
you want it
because anxiety keeps us safe until it
burns everything else to the ground
ask yourself do I want to be free from
this and if you do I got the road map
for you my brother thank you so much for
the call we'll be right back
it seems like everybody's talking about
how crazy the housing market is right
now and how powerless home buyers feel
mix that with the stress of moving and
life change and job change and you've
got a tornado of anxiety fueling one of
the biggest purchases you'll ever make
this is not a good idea so if you're a
new home buyer right now my advice to
you is to focus on what you can control
like the people you choose to help you
in the home buying process you need
folks like my friends at Churchill
Mortgage Churchill is a Ramsay trusted
provider that's been helping people with
their home mortgages for decades and
their home buyer Edge program will help
you skip a bunch of the stress here's
how it works apply to become a Churchill
certified home buyer and cap your
interest rate for 90 days then you'll
get a five thousand dollar seller
guarantee to help your offer stand out
so go ahead take a deep breath because
Churchill has your back check them out
at churchillmortgage.com deloney and get
the home buyer Edge today this is a paid
advertisement and MLS ID 1591 nmls
consumeraccess.org equal housinglender
1749 Mallory Lane Suite 100 Brentwood
Tennessee 37027 programs are for select
loan types only and not available in all
states or locations
all right we are back let's go to
Rebecca in Clarksville Georgia what's up
Rebecca
hey Dr John thank you for taking my call
of course thank you for calling what's
up
so I um am a mom of sorry
um I have two biological and one step
um the one that I'm calling about is my
son who is from my first marriage he is
almost 11.
um so recently he has gotten to where he
will get in the shower and just
essentially rinse off so he won't
shampoo
your other kids are they daughters
they are okay you have to understand
this from 11 to about 22 soap is
actually uh a boy's become allergic to
soap oh gosh that's fantastic yes it
burns their skin like lava so just want
you to know that just want you to know
oh gosh okay so he's just getting in
rinsing off
are there are there times he gets out
and you say
did you use soap and he looks at you
like you're the craziest stupid person
who's ever lived like oh what
and then you feel me
you feel nuts oh man okay I just
interrupted you so he's just hosing off
and then getting getting out what else
yeah I think
she said you have to ban body spray
you have to ban it from your home okay
you promised me you'll do that I promise
none none and if you married a guy that
wears ax body spray Rebecca
no body spray there's there's all kinds
of of health reasons well I know but but
no on behalf of all those sweet Middle
School girls no no okay get away now yes
gosh it's like secondhand smoke except
worse okay so he does use deodorant so
you have a super hygienic 11 year old
let's just put that out here he already
he is wearing deodorant and he is body
spraying himself what else
um well I mean really you know he's
pretty hygienically
um you know safe I guess you would say
um you know other than you know just not
wanting to use soap um and like you know
of course if I ask him yeah Mom of
course I did and then you know I feel
like the nagging mom who's like okay but
I don't smell any soap right
um so
let me just say this if he is getting
into a shower in a residential area in
Clarksville Georgia and just rinsing off
he is cleaner than 99 of the young 10 to
11 year olds that have ever existed in
the history of this planet just that
okay so from a is he gonna die is he
disgusting uh
he's gonna be fine okay he's he's 11.
yeah all right
there you go
you got to make peace with
in my own life
some things I can say all I want let me
I'll just speak about myself my parents
told me a lot of stuff
and some of it I just had to suffer the
social consequences because I did not
listen
ing because I was 10 or 11 or 16 or 25
or whatever yeah but at some point
someone had to say good God Delona you
stink and I had to go well okay you know
what I mean I had to wear deodorant and
or wash my gym clothes or whatever the
thing was and so I we don't want our
kids to suffer social consequences
they're going to they're going to
um
this might sound bananas okay
has anyone ever showed him how to wash
his armpits and how to clean not just
like the outer shiny part of his booty
cheeks but actually washes but wash his
feet and washes hair if no one's ever
shown him how to do it
it may be a he has no road map for this
and for you and me that sounds so dumb
because we've taken 55 000 showers in
our lifetime he hasn't and so he may
just you'd be like you need to use soap
and he may look at you go I don't know
what that means wash your armpits uh I
watched my college roommate I won't out
him which one but
uh I saw him put on deodorant and I was
like what are you doing how did you and
here's what I realized he wasn't an
athlete he hadn't been in a locker room
with hundreds of dudes and seen a
hundred different versions of how people
put on deodorant and and realized oh
there's a way that works in a way that
doesn't work you just didn't have never
seen that
so I would recommend it's going to sound
awkward and weird and if your husband
would help that would really help but
let's just give him a run through let's
teach him what we're talking about does
that sound fair
it does it does and I mean so prior I
guess I should have given you a little
back story so
um Braden and I it's kind of been uh
since he was about three okay
um and then I got remarried um actually
just this year
um so you know he's kind of a mama's boy
um and I used to always you know go in
there and sit with him while he would
shower and we would talk about his day
and things like that but I had a baby in
September last year
and so you know recently is where the
change kind of happened so I was
wondering you know if maybe this is like
an attention thing where you know Mama's
not with him all the time now is that
what he is missing it I mean it could be
but I wouldn't even good on that road
yeah
um the reality is he's 10 or 11 and 10
11 year old boys are not known globally
for their hygienic practices right and
so I I wouldn't I you're trying to
figure out a way to make this your fault
don't do that don't do that okay okay
you had a baby you got to do what you
got to do and the dynamic of your life
your relationship with your 10 year old
has changed it's a new dynamic and so
um if you valued that time with him when
you should just sit and hang out in the
shower which by the way if he's 11
you're getting borderline
right so I did not do that it would have
been time to not have shower time with
Mom or he would have been talking to one
of my colleagues in the next couple
years so here's here's the here's your
responsibilities mom if that time was
valuable to you where do I find that
time again for us
right and for me and my 12 year old we
go to breakfast once a week yeah we go
to Waffle House and we hang out and he
gets to see me over tip and he gets to
see me how I treat the waiter waitresses
and the cooks and so he's learning this
he's soaking all this up and I get to
spend some magic time with him and we
talk about gratitude and Christmas
presents and what things mean and
Science and we talk about a bunch of
stuff I also don't have two little kids
that I gotta deal with and so I'm not
casting that on you that may never
happen for you guys for a while so where
can you find that time is it a walk in
the evening is it some kind of role does
that make sense and I also let me pass
this I'm throwing a thousand things at
you so my mind's spinning here
um I had a professor Dr Aretha marbley
um she's one of my favorite people I've
ever met in my life
she gave me this wisdom whenever um we
had my son Hank and then my wife was
pregnant with Josephine
and she said you can avoid all problems
all of them by simply referring to
your your new baby as his baby she said
just refer to him as his baby
and I was like but it's not she's like
just trust me
and so as soon as my wife started
showing we started talking about his
sister and his baby and how he was gonna
help be a part of raising this young
girl and how he was gonna love her and
show her respect and dignity and what
does that mean and
and now
man I got a pretty amazing 12 year old
when it comes to to loving and honoring
and taking care of his little sister
it's not perfect they're still 12 and
six and could God help us all but it's
pretty amazing and so you teaching your
son that he's got a role to play
in the lives of these young kids
he they won the the cosmic Lottery
because they got him as an older brother
and then very directly here's what
that's going to look like so you take
him out for a walk or for a breakfast or
a dinner date or something once every
two weeks once a week and say what's one
or two things we can really do to show
the little ones that we love them this
week what's one thing you're gonna do to
love your brother and your sister right
see what I'm saying or your sister and
your sister let's give him some
ownership there right
um and I man that's where I would lean
let's now I want to go down one more
rabbit hole with you okay
nagging and complaining has never solved
anything ever okay yeah absolutely let's
take that out of the equation
um at some point the hygiene may get too
much
okay
at some point he gets to make choices
in in response to your boundaries what
does that mean
your boundaries are I do not take people
to school who have not um bathed with
soap
I do not take people to the movies or to
their practices that have not bathed
with soap
so if you want to choose to not do these
things and thereby suffer the
consequences of not choosing to do these
things great I'm going to honor that
but you hold the cards here
and it's not your punishment you didn't
do this so you don't get to go I'm not
I'm not going to weaponize your
friendships I'm not going to weaponize
these things
you're going to make choices
and if I go in the bathroom and the soap
is still dry completely bone dry you
haven't used it your little floofy thing
hasn't it's bone dry then you've just
made some choices that you're not you
don't want to go on that date that you
don't want to go to the movie you don't
want to go to that birthday party and
that's totally fine that's a choice you
made I'm not gonna fight you over
right right and this is a hard shift
because you've been you've been doing
things for him for a long time
yeah stop feeling guilty about the
divorce stop feeling guilty about stuff
and let's create let's let's be about
raising an incredible young man does
that sound fair
that sounds perfectly Fair okay one more
thing last one last one last one
I don't feel like this is me just
throwing stuff at you
this is a bougie answer okay not
everybody can do this if y'all are in a
financial position where this is
possible
take him with you to the store
and let him pick the bar of soap and let
him pick the shampoo he's going to use
let him be a part of it you tell him no
more ax body spray I don't have a
problem with ax person like no more body
sprays we're not doing body sprays gross
uh if we were supposed to have body
sprays evolution of salt for that I know
that was a terrible answer deodorant I
know I know internet people
um I was trying to be funny as I said it
I realized I'm I made myself a circular
argument it's not going to work just no
body sprays but
allow him to choose the soap allow him
to choose the shampoo and so he's got
some sort of ownership in this
he gets he's starting to learn the
choices that he gets to make right so
let's give him some autonomy on the
front end and then it becomes did you
use your soap did you use your shampoo
the one that you picked out right so
he's starting to slowly
recognize the weight of his choices and
his decisions
which is one of the greatest gifts you
can give any young kid which is to
slowly teach them the weight of being
alive because it's heavy and the longer
we carry that for him the more shock
there is when they have to pay their own
bills and make their own decisions and
deal with their rejections and get their
hearts broken all those things which we
all have to do oh man teaching them the
weight of their choices at an early age
what a gift what a gift but
you have a 10 year old or 11 year old
that seems allergic to soap
you're all right you're all right we'll
be right back
hey guys deloney here and I've got a
word from our sponsor whoop if you've
listened to the show for any length of
time you know I'm a major nerd about
Fitness sleep mental health and building
healthier life habits and let's just say
this whoop makes my nerd heart so happy
one reason I love whoop is that it's not
like all the other fitness trackers that
mix in a watch in laser lights and
smiley faces and a million notifications
and reminders that you you need to get
your steps in no whoop is a fitness
wearable that actually looks cool and
it's comfortable and it gives you data
that really matters it breaks down your
recovery your sleep and your daily
strain into a format that's easy to
interpret and some days I wake up in the
green and this tells me that I'm ready
to go attack the day and other days I
wake up in the red and I know that I
gotta take it easy and I can look back
in time and see how I got there if
you're working to be intentional and
build healthier habits whoop can help
you get there start keeping an eye on
your health and wellness at a deeper
level go to whoop dot com that's
w-h-o-o-p.com and use promo code deloni
to get 10 off your order today
oh man I'm super excited about this call
this is an update call
from the one and only Elizabeth from
Roanoke Virginia Elizabeth what are you
doing
what am I doing I'm I'm sober I'm good
I'm sobered nothing okay so you're
you're calling as with this with an
update seven months right was since we
since you and I talked
so take us all the way back to seven
months ago to now
uh well when I first called you at the
beginning of the year I was really on
the fence about quitting using marijuana
which at the time I was smoking every
day for almost a decade
and I even just re-listened to that
episode and I was really scared to stop
like that really I I really like noticed
how scared I was to stop why were you
scared to stop shortly
well I was scared because I really felt
like my feelings would be overwhelming
and I wouldn't be able to tolerate just
feeling kind of like normal feelings
okay
um I don't I don't think I brought this
up last time can I just like right as
you just said that can I tell you
something that just popped into my head
yeah
you were you were in a civil war with
yourself
you were scared of you
100
.
wow
you were scared of you
I was like how you're gonna respond to
your husband how you can respond to that
boss how you can respond to that person
cutting you off in traffic how are you
going to respond to those childhood
trauma things that you haven't dealt
with you were scared of you
yeah and so I guess for a decade we'd
helped you shut you up for a minute
right
yeah pretty much
using it so then I was really on the
fence because it wasn't really giving me
relief anymore I had a new set of
problems from using but then I had this
like scary idea of what it would be to
not be using okay so that's when I ended
up reaching out to you because I just
felt like so trapped by the decision yes
okay then what did I tell you to do
well I'm asking for a friend exactly
[Laughter]
well I think what what really made a
difference for me was to remember that
the feeling will pass
and I think that that's something I
still carry with me
because I had a tendency to feel like
the emotion I was feeling was everything
it was like my whole world I'm totally
overwhelming I couldn't cope with it and
forever it's it's everything and forever
yes
in this Jewish shall pass is like
basically making a commitment to just
say like I'll try it and that's when I
ended up following up with you after
because I did try it and it was going
well
and so now fast forward is in seven
months and I'm I'm doing great you're
still sober seven months
yep wow okay it is really really rare to
not have
one or two or a couple of weeks of like
all right let's just you know
tell me about a time have you fallen off
at all
no not one time
nope wow and if I remember correctly
you're you're married and your husband
wasn't all in and then he kind of saw
how the lights were coming on for you
and tell me about where he is
so he took about two months off okay and
now he's back to using okay he's been
really ambivalent about this the whole
time so I think he's still moving in the
direction of stopping completely but we
do have kind of different relationships
with substances and just our backgrounds
of things so
um yeah I think he's having some more
challenges but really really dedicated
to like kind of Follow The Path because
he sees how how great I've been
so this makes it even more amazing you
are somebody who is trying to
um
trying to quit eating sugar and you have
a partner who just brings gummy candies
and Twinkies into the house every day
that's that's extra hard extra actually
so you made a stone cold commitment
yeah and I was telling you when we
followed up last time it's really it was
around like my emotional health and my
mood and
like I had been dealing with depression
on and off for decades and I really
wanted that to be resolved and that's
something that I really feel has been
the biggest benefit of stopping using is
that I haven't had one depressive
episode since I stopped what do you
attribute that to
uh well you know I have to say that
maybe taking away this
this up and down all the time really
helps because like when you're high you
just want to be lazy so then if you have
anything to do you're kind of pissed off
you can't just be lazy with a lot of
extra just being annoyed
um but then the next day you're more
tired and then that makes your day
harder so then you're more likely to be
stressed and then you want to use and
it's just this kind of cycle that adds a
negative I found that it just was adding
this extra undercurrent of like
negativity
I I I mean
I think that's a brilliant Insight I
would also add to that one of the
cornerstones of healing from depression
is little wins
is teaching your body I can
and after you figure out I can that be
that morphs over time to I will
and that morphs over time to I am right
so I can not smoke this next five
minutes and then I can do the next five
minutes after that which then lets me
know I will quit all the way
which then goes to a new identity which
is I'm a person who takes care of their
body I don't do that
right
that's that's so true and I really feel
so strong now and there was even times
in the beginning where difficult
emotions and it was kind of like a
feeling of what do I do with my hands
I'm like I'm kind of awkward that I'm
doing so well
like aren't I supposed to have a
breakdown or something at this point and
so it's kind of uncomfortable to feel
balanced that I'll admit
so you have
it's it's amazing that you're saying
that because I was speaking with a
business uh owner yesterday I met with a
group of business owners
um it was a behind closed doors meeting
and one of them said
I started this practice
um
I started this practice
we were I've been running and gunning
and running and gunning this thing is
more successful than I ever could have
imagined
and I realized over time that I started
this thing out of I'll show you that I
can do this I can outrun my whatever I'm
going to earn my dad's blessing I'm
gonna keep running and running
and she said I don't know how
to run this thing in peacetime
I don't know how to say whoa we're here
we're we're making a jillion dollars our
business is good we're serving people
well
this is enough for now and she didn't
have a psychology for that or a set of
practices and that's exactly what you
just described like I know how to live
out of chaos and I know how to cover up
my emotions and I had to keep the other
half of Elizabeth quiet
I don't know how to just
say that sucks and then go about my day
all right that's a that's a new set of
skills how have you how have you leaned
into that have you practiced that new
set of skills because that's incredible
Elizabeth
thank you oh it's been tough because I
was using marijuana also to just relax I
felt like I was like on hyperdrive all
the time it was the only way I could
wind down and that it did just take
practice and a lot of self-talk to say
like it is okay to take a break or
acknowledge my boundaries because I
really wasn't acknowledging my
boundaries so now I'll be tired in the
middle of dishes and be like that's
enough dishes for now and I'll just walk
away and before that would have stressed
me out I would have pushed myself so I
got irritated and I just I'm trying to
to prioritize the bigger things like
finishing the dishes in one standing is
not necessarily the most important thing
to me maybe it is that I need to go take
a break or respond to this phone call
step away
um do something that's more fulfilling I
guess because I would get just like
either hyperdrive and then smoke and
then become like a vegetable or uh oh
ground so I'm trying to just find that
balance
I I mean you you to say you're an
inspiration is the understatement of the
year you're incredible Elizabeth
and like stop smoking weeds hard after
doing stopping anything right that
you've been doing for a decade is hard
changing at that habit is hard
but what I have found over time is what
often sends people back
is trying to get through that awkward
stage of a new way of doing life
it's just like you I love the way you
just said that it's like I don't know
what to do with my hands like I'm just
standing here and you're looking at me
but it's you looking at you right and
that is that that awkwardness is so new
and so raw and so weird
dude I'm just gonna smoke right I'm just
gonna have another drink I'm you know
I'm gonna have cheeseburger that will
make the awkward go away
and you have I don't say powered through
it but you just made peace with it this
series this season's gonna be awkward
all right
kind of like it's winter so I'm gonna
wear a jacket okay I'm not gonna fight
the weather that's a waste of my energy
and time I'll just wear a coat
right exactly and I've been really
trying to work on that like labeling
what I feel
filed out of control so now I try to say
like I feel depressed right now and try
to caveat it like it's just right now
like I feel depressed right now what do
I need to do right now and I noticed
that shift in like the framing has been
so powerful too okay I'm gonna catch
myself be like I'm stressed out and I'm
like no I'm not I feel stressed right
now I love so it really helps shift my
mentality the great uh William Glasser
is a famous psychiatrist
um and I really like a lot of his a lot
of what he wrote he would not allow his
clients to use the words I'm depressed
or I'm anxious
he made them they had to say the words
I'm depressing or I I'm anxiety in or
I'm headaching I'm back aching
they had to take ownership of the things
their body was doing in order to keep
them safe or to protect them or to keep
them from feeling awkward Etc and that's
really similar to what you're doing you
don't say the words I'm depressed you're
like nope my body has a feeling right
now it's trying to send me a message
that uh it would rather not be taking
this phone call but we're gonna take
that phone call or I might be you take
the phone call right now because I don't
have to because I'm a grown-up right you
yeah exactly so great Elizabeth
incredible okay oh thank you go ahead go
ahead so
I will also remind you that this all
started because
um at the beginning of the year my
husband and I decided that we wanted to
try to have kids and I wanted to share
that I'm actually seven months pregnant
yeah
wow everything has been like a hormonal
mess and I'm still feeling great wow
yeah congratulations boy or girl thank
you good girl
I think John's still a good name for a
girl you can make that one yeah
John X yeah that's John Heather johnetta
um Josh if that doesn't sound like a
never mind I was gonna make a
geographical joke and I won't do that
um yes John Adams sounds great I'm all
in for that I'll wear that shirt
um hey congratulations congrats congrats
congrats
um I appreciate it
know this
I'm so proud of you
so proud thank you and I'm excited for
what comes next for you guys and okay I
always have to do this and I feel like
fun ruiner.com is that okay
sure
when you have this baby
oh man it's gonna be the most amazing
wonderful thing and there's gonna be a
flood of I'm not enough and shame and
Old School drama that comes back out
that you can't it's gonna be incredible
it's like a fire two fires at the same
time
I want you to never forget I'm with you
every step of the way call me anytime
okay
I'm so so so proud of you and little
johnette has won the lottery with
um you as her mama it's gonna be so cool
man thank you so so much for calling
calling back in and checking in with us
ah my whole day it's awesome seven
months after smoking out for a decade
every day
says I'm done I'm done and I'm gonna
live with the awkward I'm so proud of
you we'll be right back
hey what's up now that my new book own
your past change your futures out in the
wild we've been hearing reviews and
feedback from readers and wow I'm so
grateful and one of the things I've been
most excited about hearing is that this
book is not just for people who are
healing from terrible traumatic
experience or other big scary things
from their past this book is for
everyone in every Walk of Life the
single 30 year old looking to sharpen
their mind the 25 year old hoping to
make new friends the parent who's tired
of seeing their kids eyes glued to a
screen but who doesn't know how to
re-enter their life people coming out of
abusive relationships everyone and this
book isn't me talking at you this book
is me walking with you because I've been
there too to better understand and
improve your mental relational and
emotional health please check out own
your past change your future at John
deloney.com today that's John
deloney.com today
all right as we wrap up today's show hey
don't forget please hit the Subscribe
button and please leave your five star
reviews if you've got three star reviews
do them on another podcast
um but but please hit the Subscribe
button on your podcast platforms on
YouTube platforms it really helps spin
the sucker up into the algorithms and
most importantly it helps other people
that may never hear about the show
find the show and get them help with
their marriage help them with their kids
that won't use soap and it can help them
celebrate they're thinking about
quitting drinking for the first time
they're thinking about going back home
after leaving
and it's going to remind them of
somebody like Elizabeth's recovery
Journey so please hit your subscribe
button it really helps other people out
thank you so so much as we wrap up
today's show my good friend or my uh
best friends here in Nashville and
incredible songwriter his name is Eric
Peters Eric Peters and he wrote a song
way back in uh I think late 2001 songs
called recovery and as a shout out to
Elizabeth here it is it's songs called
recovery by Eric Peters he writes I
found recovery in a dark and dreary cell
chained to a corner the stench of sin
the smell I fed myself portions of less
than remains and I slept in the waste of
fraudulent claims and I found myself
clinging to my odds working to narrow
the gap between the broad locked like a
slave to the pillar that's my pride at
the admission of my failures you allowed
my past to die
held for the healing I've found recovery
I found recovery
hold for the healing hold me for the
healing because I found I found recovery
and hey if this show is for nothing else
it's for that that together we're gonna
find recovery we'll see you soon
[Music]